jamie foxx just ruined spider-man no way
home
kind of
okay check this out according to screen
geek and virtually every other news
source out there jamie foxx posted up on
instagram a picture of three spider-man
with like his face right it's not really
his face i mean the image looks amazing
but like we'll post it up here so you
can see it the image looks badass but
it's basically like jamie foxx like
electrified face and it's like three
spiderman and then there was a second
image that said
chasing spiders and so everybody's like
yeah man basically now it's confirmed
toby maguire and and andrew garfield are
in the movie but here's the thing man
you know look here's here's
here's the thing you know i i totally
applaud sony's desire
to uh keep this under wraps
sony
it's the worst kept secret in the
history of hollywood
it's the worst kept secret everyone
knows
it's time to stop pretending
and here's the funny thing it's not even
sony it's marvel studios right like sony
were the ones who were like let's put
them in there like everybody basically
knows us there marvel studios are the
ones you're like no we have to maintain
the suspension of disbelief and i kind
of understand both sides to a degree
right i mean
it changes things when you definitively
know right like if like jamie foxx
alludes to it and you can kind of be
like well you know it depends on how you
interpret it right you know or if like
the lizard's head just suddenly gets
knocked to the side by what's obviously
a fist from a person who's been removed
like literally the lizard got punched in
the face and they removed the person who
did it
they could say was a strong gust of wind
you know
you know how it is you know out there
when you're when you're fighting really
high up you know the wind's strong yeah
planes and turbulence you can find some
way to cook the books to make it work
but then when you see a trailer and then
you see like andrew garfield or toby
maguire unmask it throws away all the
disbelief so i can really see where both
sides are coming from
but come on man
we already know what's going on
we already know they're in there here's
who i want to see right i mean it's cool
that we get toby mcguire and it's even
better that we get andrew garfield
switch that it's cool that we get andrew
garfield it's even better that we get
together mcguire uh
but
at the end of the day
i still want to see miles morales man
miles morales i want to see miles more
house look okay don't don't leave don't
leave right don't leave
stay with me here
we know miles morales exists in the mcu
right we know he's there if miles
morales were going to show up in this
movie it wouldn't be in the main film
itself right i mean it would just it
would feel forced you know what i mean
like hey everyone it's miles morales how
did he get here don't worry about that
just be happy he's here like that that
would basically be the movie uh it'd be
a problem
it would feel forced he would just feel
shoved in there he's so spectacular of a
character
uh
i have to man i have to guys i can't not
do this
he's so spectacular of a spider-man
god i'm corny he's so spectacular of a
character that he deserves to be put in
there in a proper way
so i say post-credit scenes
honestly it kind of makes sense right so
those are guys who are unfamiliar with
that i feel like we may have talked
about this before i'm not 100 sure but
maya's morales is an ultimate universe
character right so in the ultimate
universe this is what the mcu is based
off of that peter parker was bitten by a
radioactive spider that was an attempt
by norman osborne the green goblins
company to duplicate the super soldier
serum that made steve rogers into
captain america miles morales ends up
being bitten by a spider from the same
corporation and so because that he ends
up becoming spider-man but i love the
character of miles and the reason why is
because for those of you guys who don't
read comics a lot of characters like
peter parker they're legacy characters
they're old school characters they've
been around for a very very very long
time peter's had a lot of stories told
about him but in a lot of ways peter
just feels old hat he feels like he's
just been around the block a few times
and he kind of seems to lack that
youthful exuberance that a lot of modern
characters have so a really good example
of this is sam alexander also known as
nova those of you guys who have been
reading the different leaks and rumors
and so on and so forth going around the
mcu a lot of you have heard that richard
ryder nova is supposed to appear in
guardians of the galaxy 3. i don't know
if that's true it's just something that
i've heard so far not a big advocate of
that i would much rather see sam
alexander he's young he's exciting he's
funny he's a character where like he
gets powers and he's like man i have
powers this is amazing he reacts the way
any of us would react if we were a kid
who was suddenly done with powers but
with miles morales it is a little bit
different because miles morales story is
more grounded in the gritty realism of
the world that we live in that's what
the ultimate universe was designed to be
it was designed to be an answer to the
question what if superheroes appeared in
the modern day as it existed in the year
2000 as you guys know a lot's changed in
the last 21 years but in the year 2000
when the ultimate universe was launched
it was designed to answer that question
by the time miles came around a lot of
things had changed right peter parker
had basically died different things
along those lines but a lot of things
had changed the important thing here is
that miles character is a part black
part latino character he basically goes
to a charter school for those of you
guys who don't know what that is is
essentially a system set up whereby
individuals who were in very difficult
places right very very poor places can
basically win a lottery bid to go to a
better school now even they have their
own problems but it's a reflection of
inner city life more so than that while
that kind of stuff is important what
matters the most when it comes to the
character of miles morales is him
becoming spider-man what made this so
significant is that when he was
initially introduced in marvel comics
fans didn't like it right fans love him
now but they hated him at the time a lot
of people hated miles morales because
peter parker was killed off literally
brian michael bendis the writer killed
off the ultimate spider-man peter parker
people just they weren't ready for it
right i mean literally peter parker in
the ultimate universe is what made the
ultimate universe popular prior to that
and then following that miles morales
came in and then became spider-man the
way in which this transition happened is
that eventually brian michael bendis
wrote a story called spider-man which is
where peter parker from the maine marvel
universe meets miles morales from the
ultimate universe and basically says hey
man it sucks that your universe is peter
parker died but keep doing your thing
basically there's ryan michael bendis
telling fans to shut up and miles
morales isn't going anywhere and they
largely did and then they became fans of
miles morales as time went on when they
gave the comic a chance and so that kind
of a thing is significant now tie that
into the marvel cinematic universe say
for example that tom holland dies in
this movie or he just kind of gets
shunted back off to the sony verse and
that's it he's going to spend his time
forevermore making movies that are
strictly based on sony i don't think any
of that's going to happen and we'll talk
about why here in a minute kind of
reiterate a few points that we've made
from previous videos but i think a great
way for the marvel cinematic universe to
have capitalized on that is for a deal
to have been worked out between the two
where sony keeps peter parker and the
marvel cinematic universe gets miles
morales and miles morales goes forward
as spider-man the real question is would
audiences accept him or would they
reject him i don't really know
especially when you consider that in the
grand scheme of the marvel cinematic
universe's history we really haven't
gotten much of tom holland's spider-man
we've seen him for what amounts to a
couple movies and that's basically it
right like about three well we're
getting four movies now but about three
movies up to this point right if you
don't include civil war or any of that
stuff we've seen some things but we
haven't really seen tom hall and
spider-man step into his own become his
own superhero he was the protege of iron
man he worshipped captain america as a
hero it was always him just kind of
following behind somebody else and
learning the ropes of what it meant to
be a superhero not really him out on his
own learning what it means to do things
on his own and calling it a day even in
spider-man far from home he was working
with shield but in terms of him just
being out there by himself doing his
thing we haven't really seen that yet
and i think it's only a matter of time
before we do assuming the mcu gets to
keep him but talking about the points
we've kind of mentioned before i don't
think that's actually what's going to
happen if i'm honest with you guys here
i think what you're seeing with regards
to the spell of doctor strange the
events of loki the multiverse crossing
over it's the marvel cinematic
universe's equivalent of the multiversal
collapse from marvel comics it's all
going to coalesce into a singular
universe i'm very much sticking by that
theory i could be entirely wrong which
really begs the question should we just
start calling these left field right
because these theories are just out in
left field and who knows if they're
going to come to fruition or not
but i i very much think that's what's
going to happen i very much think that
what's going to come out of all of this
between the events of loki and spiderman
no way home and doctor strange too is
you're basically going to end up seeing
the entire multiverse as the mcu has
created it so the fox movies that they
now own the sony universe that sony
still has the rights to they all get
merged into a singular universe going
forward and that following this
basically whenever a spider-man solo
film comes out sony gets all the cash
for that and whenever spider-man appears
on anything in the mcu the mcu gets
money for that and that's basically it
that's how they split the difference so
tom holland isn't going anywhere tom
holland is going nowhere that kind of
begs the question what are we going to
see from the villains in spider-man no
way home which i want to reach out to
you guys for what do you guys think is
going to happen the villains that are
there doctor octopus and green goblin
electro lizard sandman which are only
five we still have a six that we're
waiting on if we're really going to see
a true sinister six what do you think is
gonna happen to these villains and who
do you think the sixth man is that's
really the big question to ask here to
be honest with you guys coming off the
trailers that we saw who do you guys
think the sixth member of the sinister
six is going to be do you think it's
gonna be morbius i've heard a lot of
theories out there that it's gonna be
more obvious i don't know it seems kind
of weird to thrust morbius into that
role but regardless we're gonna bring
this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace